David Cone has a new book it's called
full count the education of a pitcher at
he wrote with great journalist Jack
curry and David Cone I believe I was
correct he won five World Series titles
yes where are the rings I keep mine
storage hey I'm an airhead I might lose
them so Alan charity events I break them
out but number you know I'll leave it on
the hotel bed you know on the nightstand
but they're gonna gaudy looking yeah
they're hard to wear they really are and
they've gotten bigger over the years
every year there's another topper on top
of another one do you know anybody who
lost a World Series ring
oh yeah you see him on eBay every now
and then too and they though I lost it
and it's just some you know somebody's
trying to sell it if you could only keep
one what ring
I would I would keep the ninety-eight
ring 98 Yankees won 125 games lost 50 at
the end of the day you know I mean it's
in the argument you know maybe top five
teams of all time certainly the entire
roster we had strawberry on the bench
Tim Raines on the bench that year young
kid named Homer Bush it was the deepest
team I've ever been a part of but you
also you know the Yankees changed that
whole bullpen routine when you had
wetland
you know so Moe is a well you know he's
the guy who was going to come in prior
to wetland come in Ramiro Mendoza came
in for from Oh like that sort of changed
baseball when you had a hammer coming in
before the hammer it really did and you
go back to 1996 when Rivera as you said
was setting up wetland music that was
probably Mariano's best year he pitched
over 100 innings we used him two or
three innings at a time and in Game six
of 96 in the World Series against the
Braves when Mariano Rivera came in the
sixth inning he came over we just knew
it we had the lead Joe Girardi hit a big
triple off of Greg Maddux to give us a
lead early in that game and the minute
Moe got in that game that early we knew
that this game is over there are certain
players in certain sports where they
were automatic you know Kareem when he
take his skyhook I Rivera fits in there
that it just felt like whenever he went
to the mound that it was over even
though you know it wasn't he lost some
tough games Red Sox he lost to the
Diamondbacks but I don't know if is
there another baseball player you can
think of where you just sort of said
it's automatic yeah he was so efficient
his control the combination
movement and velocity was just so good I
mean most pitchers and we talked about
earlier Dan and anytime you start
twisting your wrist and start making the
baseball move you lose velocity and
Rivera was the exception he still threw
the ball 95 miles an hour that cut in on
left-handed batters about six inches so
we've really never seen somebody with
that combination of movement and
velocity and precision Mark Grace once
told me that if you're not cheating
you're not trying do you believe that
wow there's gamesmanship you know
there's blurred lines there certainly in
baton in the baseball world and all the
unwritten rules now what would be
gamesmanship for you on the mound like
how far would you stretch gamesmanship
well I would not have an emery emery
board in my back pocket okay now and try
to scuff the ball but if I threw one in
the dirt and I got a nice scuff on and I
knew what to do with it so to me that's
that's good one chip what do you do with
it when you know you have a scuff well
with a scuff it depends on which side of
the ball you hold this guff if the scuff
is perfectly located on the ball you put
it on the left side it dives to the
right so it goes the opposite way the
movement on the pitch will move the
opposite ways of the scuff let's say you
got something on your glove that all of
a sudden is a little sharper than you
probably thought it was going to be or
should be
that's cheating that there's blurred
lines again there the pine tar is really
a big issue nowadays we used to think
that pine tar just helped you in cold
weather it didn't improve your spin rate
well now we know it does and then that
it's been proven with some of the new
technology that little extra sticky
stuff on your fingers can help your
curveball break a little better a little
sharper where would you hide it I had it
on my belt had it on my glove
I got a cop out here it's true okay I
did I cheated no there's a lot of I
think it's rare when a pitcher doesn't
yeah you sure I mean especially in bad
weather and cold weather in April or
even in October sometimes yeah you can't
feel you can't feel the baseball and the
baseball's are pretty slick sometimes
you know this whole thing of rubbing up
baseball's with Mississippi mud or their
Delaware mud now wherever it's from but
there's no consistency to it and it's
remarkable to in today's day and age
we're still getting a bucket of mud and
trying to rub up baseball's and they're
all different and some are darker than
others and it just makes no sense
you've talked about this in your book
where you know the certain pitchers tip
their pitches it feels like every
pitcher has a tell is that safe to say
yes I think everybody has something you
know some obviously more discernible
than others like Clayton Kershaw has a
tell right I'm sure he does yeah
who had the tell like it's weird if you
know there's a tell and you're on the
other team and let's say you're friends
with somebody do you tell the pitcher
they have a tell if you're friends with
them that's a tough one have you when
they became teammates when they're on
your side and then they finally fess up
and Tommy or was that guy for me
the second baseman for the Cardinals for
years just wore me out and then when he
came over and was was a member of the
Mets it took him about two or three
months before he finally came to me and
told me hey yeah
you Tippin your pitches this is what
you're doing and how many years had you
been tipping your pitches she said
probably the first three or four years
of my career and what were you doing on
breaking balls you know usually you have
the ball in your glove and on breaking
balls or splitters I would drop the
glove down and get the grip right there
and then go back up over my head and I'm
fast balls I would just immediately cuz
I already had the fastball I would take
the glove and no drop in the glove and
just take it right over my head it was
that obvious man
I remember I remember Mark Grace who's
one the great hitters of all time he
said that he had a friend who was a
pitcher on the opposing team and he told
him because he was a friend even though
it was gonna probably hurt a lot of
other people he said he couldn't he
couldn't help but you know I had to tell
him friendship I guess yeah I mean I
don't know that's the blurred lines
there I don't know I mean that's that's
a tricky one
well we've questioned Grace's sanity
before he's David Cone and the new book
is out why'd you decide to write a book
well it was really Jack Curry's idea and
he came to me and I love Jack I mean
he's such a trustworthy great journalist
and kind of a pitchy nerd and you know
after being a broadcaster for ten years
I have a little different perspective on
things so we kind of wanted to get
current and then go back yeah it's even
to the Mets days and kind of revisit
some of these issues and do a little
different twist on an autobiographical
style of book and yeah it's honest it's
raw you know
I talk about some of them some of the
mistakes I made along the way and and
take you inside what I was thinking at
the time also the relationship with your
catcher is tricky because I might like
you but you're not the best catcher for
me how do you find the catchers that's
best for you that is so important so
underrated even in today's game you know
even with some of the new metrics you
talk about framing ability or the value
you can place on catchers nowadays it
goes much deeper than that you almost
have to be a psychoanalyst with with
flakes like me on the mound and you know
we go into some of my meltdowns on the
mound I mean why don't you melt down so
much you know it was just the the
emotional nature the makeup of any
person any pitcher sometimes you're
under you wait a week to pitch and in
five minutes your week is ruined
sometimes and it turns you into a
lunatic on the mound sometimes and they
did nothing like a starting pitcher in
all of sports so much responsibility
every pitch plus you have so much dead
time you've got a way to pitch so making
a little little nutty at times what's
the one that stands out that you'd love
to take back well there's so many but
yeah I am the guy who argued with an
umpire first base and allowed to Atlanta
baserunners to score not one to two
scored and they were the slowest runners
in the history of the game Dale Murphy
and Ernie wit why I screamed it I was
out he was out Charlie Williams was the
first base umpire a long time on fire
yeah he finally told me he said while
you're arguing with me the second runner
just scored I went all right that
cleared some of this stuff up you didn't
have a baseball team in high school did
not this the school didn't feel the team
so I played in a summer league that was
a college league when I was 15 so
playing against 21 and under at 15 years
old you spent five years in the minors
you got called up with the Royals but
you got traded to the Mets because of
behavioral of behavioral issues well I
still have those things but I I butted
heads with a lot of pitching coaches and
I think that's kind of a theme in the
book that that's okay and I'm sure in
your career you've done the same thing
with producers or directors or you name
the question and the pushback is okay
and they tried to change my style all
the way they didn't want me dropping
down throwing sidearm they
my arm angle up up top they tried to
change a little wrist break that I had
in my delivery and all these things were
natural and I thought were important and
I push back push back got a reputation
for being kind of a rebel and that sent
me to the rebel Mets on the heels of the
86 World Series and then you threw a
perfect game against the Expos what do
you remember about that perfect game
well I remember warming up before the
game it was Yogi Berra day at Yankee
Stadium and it was all about Yogi so Don
Larsen was there Don Larsen was there it
was just a happy-go-lucky day at Yankee
Stadium yogi finally healed with his
problems with George Steinbrenner's
about 15 years for Yogi to be away from
the Yankees and then you know I just it
was so happy go-lucky I wasn't the story
I was carefree and in some ways it was a
great distraction for me just to think
about Yogi and not worry about pitching
you you were always known as a prankster
that was when your curveball and your
Frank ability is what I knew about you
when I was I was around that team what's
the best prank you ever pulled I can't
really I mean yeah there are you up
there with Greg Maddux the Maddux is
dirty - he's definitely ok I'm not quite
on maddux's level or Roger McDowell even
oh yeah it was pretty give me one for
air you got a prank for air oh jeez yeah
there was one ok the 2000 Subway Series
the middle three games were at Shea
Stadium we're playing the Mets and
George Steinbrenner rearranged the whole
furniture at Shea Stadium he wanted
Yankee emblems on the chairs he hated
that we were sitting in Mets chairs so
he brought a moving truck over all the
furniture he sat there and there's a row
of cables for the television on the
floor and I went to George and I said
those those aren't supposed to be here
the Mets they're bugging us they're
stealing our signs George the man he bit
hook line and sinker he got down on his
hands and knees started yanking those
cables and then he was gonna go complain
to Bud Selig the Commissioner and then
he looked at me and I was red-faced and
laughing he charged a me George ran at
me got real beef be red-faced and he got
me in a hammerlock and I
George Steinbrenner got you in a
headlock during the World Series he did
and in the middle games at Shea Stadium
and then I started laughing he said you
better be ready to pitch young man and
have you told that story before
yeah well no I I've told different
versions of that story but not that the
full extent of oh wow so here's one of
the most powerful guys in baseball and
he's your boss and he got you in a
headlock a full headlock but how long
did you room with David wells just that
one year really was that was probably
best for both of you there yeah it was
best I mean that was a crazy year we
every every time we went on the road we
stayed away from the team hotel and I
made this arrangement with Tori Tori
didn't know we were staying away from
the team hotel but I told Tori let me
have boomer I'll keep him out of jail
because he was driving Tori crazy that
year and I said I got him this is my guy
I got him and then we became great
friends that year and had some great
parties on the road and actors musicians
would show up and oh I know Charlie
Sheen showed up yeah Charlie Sheen
definitely was part of that go Charlie I
mean they I think he was probably in the
middle some of his issues or him that
there ever was not issues knowledgeable
baseball guy great baseball fan really
he was so good to us and boomer and him
really really clicked they they seemed
to see eye to eye on a lot of issues
Metallica yeah large said David Wells
named his kid Lars after the drummer for
Metallica Lars anybody else show up one
night matthew mcconaughey showed up and
some of his pissed friends and we did
that play we didn't bail Bongo no bond
Oh naked make no naked bongos no but but
he was he was great too he was a big
baseball fan a lot of fun do you believe
that boomer was hungover when he threw
his he was always fascinating I mean and
plus you know he was one of those guys
who told you whether he wanted to hear
it he told it to no filter at all with
boomer and you know he's got a big heart
he's a good guy once you get to know him
but he's a rebel I mean the stories of
him and his
mother attitude Annie was she was in the
Hells Angel or she was he was she was
she was the the girlfriend of the leader
of the San Diego Chapter of Hells Angels
so that was his little leagues you know
as little leagues was all hike a
twelve-year-old little league game and
it's all bikers and there's boomer
pitching you're gonna get the call I
think if the Hells Angels are there
rooting for you if your mom was in the
Hells Angels you know I know we talked
about some of the personality stuff here
the peripheral stuff here but if you
want to know about pitching and this is
good bad and ugly that David you know he
shares a lot here the education of a
pitcher the book is called full count
and Jack curry is one of the great
baseball writers of our time so if you
it's been likened to kind of a bull
durham field to this book where there's
a lot of stories in there but there's a
lot of truth and a lot of insight in
there as well and I wish you well with
the book David thank you Dan great to be
on with you for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]